Okay, so
the question we are looking at today is
how did English how did England become
the greatest empire in human history?
This is about the 19th century when the
British Empire
is at its peak. As you can see
it really controls most of the world.
So the question then is how did this
happen?
Why is it that England was able to
surpass Spain,
France, Germany,
the Holy Roman Empire,
Russia become the dominant hegemon in
the world. So my argument to you today
is it has to do with the fact that
throughout its history England was
forced to innovate in a more rigorous
and relentless way
than other nations. And a lot has to do
with its geography.
Okay, so as you can see from its
geography Great Britain, this is
Ireland, this is England, Wales,
Scotland, it is an extremely mountainous
region.
And with very they have a lot of rivers,
but there are no major rivers. Which
mean which meant that for most of its
history
Britain never had a major population
center that could grow and grow until it
overwhelm the entire geographic
area.
This meant that for most of its history
England
Britain was engaged in a in a process
what what we call open competitive
cooperation.
Not only that, but because
this area um
is very mountainous, and because these
groups, these tribes are divided
um heavily amongst themselves,
throughout most of its history, Britain
is actually pretty easy to invade. They
have no centralized authority, so it's
possible for um other groups of people
to come and create settlements in
Britain, which is what the Vikings did,
which is also what
the Romans, the Amnaya uh so throughout
its history,
Britain had undergo had underwent a
series of great destruction, where the
elites were constantly replaced by new
elites.
Okay? And because Britain is poor,
because there's so much conflict uh
within Britain, eventually um the
English people were forced to migrate
overseas to create new opportunities.
Um and this process of colonial
expansion led to the British Empire.
Okay? So there's a famous saying
that the British Empire was founded by
accident. Okay? There was no intention
to create this empire, but because of
these historical, geographic,
demographic forces,
Britain became the world's largest
empire.
Um
let's very quickly look at
Britain's demographic history. So for
most of its of its history, because of
its geography, because of the fact that
it was poor and divided, the population
of Britain stayed very flat, okay? Up
until the year 1000. What happened in
year 1000? Well, Europe became wealthier
and wealthier, um and engaged in a
proto-industrial
and agricultural revolution, which
caused demographic the the demographic
to increase.
But unfortunately,
if your demographics increase, but you
don't have improvements in sanitation,
in health, and nutrition, well, what
happens? You have something called the
Black Death, which causes entire
population
Europe, including Britain, to collapse.
Okay? Um after the Black Death, um the
Europeans start to engage in the the
gunpowder revolution.
Um and with that, you have
industrialization, urbanization, and
that causes population increase. But if
you see about the middle of the 16th
cent- 17th century up until the about
year up until about 1800, the population
is flat.
This is what we call the Industrial
Revolution in Britain.
Britain is the first European nation to
undergo the Industrial Revolution. And
what And what that meant is you have
this mass migration from the rural areas
into the urban areas, especially London.
Okay? So, why would this population or
demographic shift cause the population
to stay flat? Well, the first reason is
it's really, really unsafe in the
cities. Diseases, malnutrition,
a lack of sanitation cause people to die
really, really young. Also, during this
time, because of the massive inequality
in Britain, people are forced to migrate
overseas in order to seek better
opportunities, mainly America. But they
will also go to Australia and New
Zealand. So, even though the Dutch were
the first to discover and settle
Australia and New Zealand, it is really
the British who, because of pressure
back home, they will settle in
Australia and New Zealand. And And
today, Australia and New Zealand, of
course,
British. They have a British culture
instead of a Dutch culture, okay? Um
starting in about the year 1800, because
of improve- improvements in nutrition,
sanitation, the population explodes. All
right? And this is true for throughout
Europe. And this is really why Europe
will eventually
uh conquer the world.
All right.
So, let's go briefly into the uh history
of the British Isles.
So, at first, we believe that the
British Isles were settled by um
an agricultural people. Okay? These are
the people who built Stonehenge.
Now, if you remember way back to
beginning of this course, um
um back in September, I discussed
Göbekli Tepe, right? Göbekli Tepe is a
temple
um in Anatolia, in what is modern-day
Turkey, that shows that the desire for
humans to settle down and and found
religious societies. Well, Göbekli Tepe
is very similar to
Stonehenge. They are both as as as as
astronomical calendars that measure um
the stars, measure time, and try to
bring divine energy onto
uh the Earth in order in order to feed
agriculture, okay? So,
um you can argue that what's happening
is the Göbekli Tepe culture is spreading
all throughout Europe, and it gets into
the British Isles. But eventually, these
people are conquered by the Yamnaya,
okay? And if you look at the DNA
evidence, a lot of these people were
eventually wiped out by the Yamnaya and
replaced. This is a process of creative
destruction that will happen throughout
British history.
Um the next major development is the
Roman conquest of Britain. When the
Romans conquer Britain, they bring Roman
technology, which is which is aqueducts,
irrigation, um uh urbanization.
They will also bring Roman customs,
especially law.
Okay? So, now you have a legal tradition
in Britain that continues on to today.
Um, they will found a city called
Londinium, which is now modern-day
London, on off the River Thames, okay?
And this city will eventually become uh
the the largest city in Europe.
After the Romans will come a new group
of people who are Germanic, okay? So
these are people who used to live in
Denmark and northern Germany. And
because of population pressure, they're
all forced to migrate overseas, and they
settle in Britain. There are three
different tribes of people that settle
in Britain. They are the Angles, the
Saxons, and the Jutes. And together we
will collectively call them the
Anglo-Saxons.
And at this point in history, this
culture, this language, it's no
different from that of Germany, okay? So
if you were to go to this place in the
about the year 800,
they're speaking the same language,
which is West Germanic, and today we
call it Old English.
Um, again, what's really important to
remember is it's fairly easy to settle
down in Britain because there's no
centralized authority. So after the
Anglo-Saxons comes the Vikings from
Denmark, okay? And
um there even though England has no
major rivers, it has still has uh
rivers. So it's fairly easy for the
Vikings with their very fast long ships
to come and make settlements. So as you
can see, the Danelaw are territory that
is ceded by the Anglo-Saxons to the
Vikings, okay? And now you have this
merger of the Viking culture with the
Anglo-Saxon culture.
This process of creative destruction
continues with the Norman Conquest
of England. This is the year 1066. This
battle is called the Battle of Hastings
in which William the Conqueror of
Normandy in France, he comes and
conquers the um the the the British
Isles, okay? Um
Britain, okay? This is significant for
two reasons. The first reason is
that
the Normans are Vikings who settled down
in
Fran- in France in an area called
Normandy that's off the British coast.
And remember, before the Anglo-Saxons uh
were Germanic people, so their focus was
on northern Europe. Because the Normans
conquer Britain, Britain now is united
with parts of France, okay? So Britain
is drawn into the politics of France,
which will lead to something called the
Hundred Years' War it in which um
Britain the English are trying to
maintain their territory in France.
Okay, so that's the first major
geopolitical consequence of the Norman
Conquest. The second consequence, uh
which is also relatively significant, is
a radical change in the English
language. So before the Anglo-Saxons
spoke a Germanic language we call Old
English. Now you have a merger of the
Germanic language with French and Latin.
So French is what the is the language
that the Normans spoke, but Latin is the
official language of the educated elite
of Europe, okay? So now you have Latin
and French elements blend into Old
English and this creates a new language
we call Middle English.
And in Middle English, of course, will
give rise to Modern English. This is
significant because what makes Middle
English different from um and from Old
English is Middle English is a lot
easier to learn because remember,
now you have a very cosmopolitan nature
to Britain. You have Vikings, you have
Anglo-Saxons, you have French, you have
Normans. They all need to speak one
language. So, the best elements of these
different languages are blended into
Middle English. And this tradition
continues today because if you think
about it, English is the most widely
spoken language in the world. Why?
Because it's the easiest to learn.
All right. Now, you may argue that, you
know, it's because we live in the
Anglo-American empire and therefore
people are incentivized to learn
English. But at the same time, what I
will show you uh next class is
um
the reason why they were able to
establish the Anglo-American empire a
lot has to do with the fact that English
is easy to learn and therefore it's
easier to spread soft power, right?
Because you when you learn a language,
you're not just learning a language,
you're also learning a culture. You're
learning a history, right? And this is
what we call soft power. And the British
did this better than anyone else. Now,
the Americans do this better better than
anyone else, okay? But it starts with
the Norman Conquest 1066.
All right.
All right. Now, so
as I mentioned, what's really important
um
about Britain is it really never had
centralized authority. Maybe now and
then you had a great king like Alfred
the Great,
right? But it was never centralized
because the king could never assert
assert authority over the different
fiefdoms.
So, whenever a king does that, the
nobles get together and they rebel. So,
in 1215, King John tries to impose taxes
on the uh nobles in order to finance
wars in France,
right? Because again, uh the English are
trying to maintain their territory in
France. And they come and that creates a
lot of conflict with the French
themselves.
So, they fought a lot of wars and you
need money to pay for these wars. So,
King John was trying to make the nobles
pay taxes. So, what the nobles do, and
this is this is going to be consistent
pattern throughout British history is
they rebel and they force King John to
sign a document called the Magna Carta.
Okay, the Great Charter.
And the Great Charter is significant
because
it severely limits the power of the
king.
Now, this has happened throughout human
history before when the nobles uh rebel
and they force a compromise with the
king. This has happened throughout human
history, but this is actually the first
time that this has this has been written
down and become part of the British
tradition.
Okay, this will become part of what we
call the British constitution. What
makes the British constitution unique is
it's not written down. It's not
um a document like the US constitution
is. It is a set of traditions and norms.
Okay? So, this this begins the British
constitution, the Magna Carta.
Right, what what I want to do now is
look at different
um clauses in the Magna Carta. It's a
very old document, so most of the
stipulation, most of the clauses don't
really apply, but there are three that
do apply, okay? So, I I want us to just
look at very closely at certain clauses
within the Magna Carta.
All right, clause 10.
If anyone who has borrowed a sum of
money from Jews dies before the debt has
been repaid, his heir shall pay no
interest on the debt. Okay, this is
really interesting. This is year 1215,
there are Jews in England, okay? Why are
there Jews in England? Okay.
So, let me explain the history of um
Europe at this time. So, Europe is
entirely Catholic. The Catholic religion
does not allow for something called
usury.
And the the idea of usury is you charge
interest
on debt.
Okay, because that goes against
uh the teachings of the Catholic church.
That goes against the teaching of God.
Also, it's socially destructive, right?
Because if you're on a debt, you're
actually stuck there for all eternity.
So, the Catholic Church for explicitly
forbids
uh charging interest on debt.
But, this is really important, debt is
extremely profitable.
So, the way that the king and the
nobility get around
this taboo is they get Jews,
okay, to
lend out money and to charge debt.
And then the king gets part of that,
right? Also, because um Jews are heavily
disliked anyway because they engage in
money lending and usury, the king also
gets them to go collect taxes,
right? So, the Jews throughout European
history have been the scapegoats for the
elite.
They're the ones who charge usury.
They're the ones who
collect taxes. They're also the ones who
will engage in
uh businesses for the nobles, okay? So,
they basically subcontract businesses
from the nobles, and they're very good
at that.
All right? And why do Jews agree to do
this? Because the king and nobles
provide protection to the Jews.
Um so, over time you have this huge
problem where even nobles owe money to
the Jews.
And the if the problem of debt creates a
lot of social tension within England, so
in the Magna Carta it says very
explicitly that yes, you still owe money
to Jews, but if you die, your heir does
not have to pay interest. Because the
problem of debt, again, is not the debt
itself, the principal, but the interest.
Okay?
All right, so does that make sense to
you guys? All right, this is really
important because if you want to
understand World War II, if you want to
understand the Holocaust, it starts way
back here, okay?
All right. So, the two most important
clauses in the Magna Carta that still
apply today is 39 and 40. All right, so
let's look at 39. No free man shall be
seized or imprisoned
except by the lawful judgment of his
equals or by the law of the land. This
creates a new principle in British
history called due process.
This means that if you are if you commit
a crime,
you are still guaranteed
a jury, a trial before you are punished.
Right? There's a process in which you
are
uh found guilty for your crime. This is
what we call due process.
Number 40, to no one will we sell, to no
one deny or delay right or justice.
This means
that
no one is above the law, okay? So,
number 30 establishes the idea of due
process. Number 40 establishes the idea
of rule of law. Everyone is guaranteed
due process. Not even the king has the
power and authority to take away due
process from someone.
All right? And this establishes the
British common law tradition. And this
becomes the basis for the American
Constitution, all right?
Okay. So, as I mentioned, because of the
Norman Conquest, Britain now is forced
to defend its territory in France, and
this leads to a series of disastrous
wars
in France called the Hundred Years War.
I don't have time to go into the
history, but obviously there are certain
very important figures that emerge from
the Hundred Hundred Years War, the most
famous being Joan of Arc, okay? Joan of
Arc, who is this French mystic, a
teenager uh girl who leads the French
armies to victory against the British
and their allies.
All right? Um
During this time, there's also a civil
war fought in Britain called the War of
the Roses between the House of York and
the House of Lancaster. You may like the
Game of Thrones
television series. I'm not sure if you
watched it, but that series is actually
based on the civil war between the House
of York and the House of Lancaster. This
goes on for a long time. It's very very
deadly. It almost destroys Britain. But
eventually, a man named Richard of York,
Richard the Third, he emerges victorious
from this civil war.
Okay? But he has a problem.
His problem is his family, the House of
York, had to borrow a lot of money from
overseas, the Florentines, right? The
Medicis, in order to finance the war.
Once he became king, he he thought,
"Well, I'm king and I don't have to pay
you back, okay?" So now the bankers are
angry at him. And if bankers are angry
at you, you have a problem. Because what
bankers will do in the circumstance is
finance an invasion
of your country, okay? So the Medicis,
the Florentine bankers, they sponsored a
man named Henry Tudor, Henry Tudor, who
is of the House of Lancaster, okay? But
he grew up in in France.
And they sponsored him to invade England
and defeat Richard the Third.
Okay? And this is obviously the House of
Tudor.
And the And so, um
the um
the uh Henry Tudor becomes Henry the
Seventh, and his son becomes Henry the
Eighth, who is most one of the most
famous kings
in British history. He's famous because
he decides
to
negate the authority of the Pope.
He decides, "I'm the king. I don't have
to listen to anyone, even the Pope,
okay?" And this came to pass because
Henry Eighth was trying to divorce
Catherine of Aragon, and the Pope would
not agree. So the the Henry Eighth
decided to set up his own church called
the Church of England
and separate himself from the Vatican.
Now,
what's really important to for us to
remember is there's only one difference,
only one difference between the Church
of England and the Catholic Church. The
Catholic Church
swears loyalty to the Pope. The Church
of England swears loyalty to the King of
England. That's it, guys. There's no
other difference. The customs, the
doctrine, the rituals are all the same.
Okay? There's only one difference.
Um
He will have a very famous daughter
called Queen Elizabeth. All right? So,
um because of the Reformation,
there's a huge
religious civil war going on within the
Catholics
and the Protestants.
Okay? So, Elizabeth, why she is so
consequential is she's on the throne for
40-plus years. And what makes her
extremely significant is she brings
stability to England by sympathizing
with the Protestants, but but also by
working with the Catholics, okay? So,
even though there are all these Catholic
conspiracies against Elizabeth in order
to instill install a uh Catholic
monarch. Um
It she's she's still able to resist
these conspiracies, these rebellions,
and establish a pretty stable nation.
At the same time, dur- during her reign,
uh Shakespeare will write his plays.
Next class, we are doing Shakespeare,
okay? Because of Shakespeare, there
would be no English language. If there's
no English language, you can also argue
there'd be no British Empire. So, next
class we'll spend an entire class on
analyzing how Shakespeare created the
English language
and created the possibility of the
British
Empire, okay? That's next class.
Um
Francis Drake is the most famous pirate
at this time.
And
he is a trusted deputy of Elizabeth.
Elizabeth has a policy of piracy, right?
England is poor, Spain is rich, so what
do you do? You steal from the rich and
you give to the poor, right? And that's
what Sir Sir Francis Drake did. Um so
at this time, England is emerging as a
naval power and it's it's going to
surpass both Spain and France become the
dominant navy in the world. And as you
know, it's really the navy that allows
the British Empire to control the world.
Um the major innovation of the British,
of the English, is how they fight at
sea.
Traditionally,
the way you fight naval battles is by
ramming the enemy and then boarding the
ship and then killing everyone, okay?
That's what the Romans did. That's what
everyone did.
The
English decided that's silly because
we're always outnumbered. We're always
outmanned, okay? So they pioneered
long-range cannon warfare, where from a
distance, maybe a few hundred meters,
you will blast your enemy with cannons.
There are lots and lots of problems with
this, okay? The first problem is
um you could possibly sink your ship
because the cannons are very heavy.
Also, you could blow up your own ship
because the cannons are very explosive.
Also, the cannons aren't very accurate,
okay?
So but the English persisted even though
you can make the argument that this um
type of warfare is unsustainable, okay?
And in the beginning for the first
few decades, the way they fought was
terrible. But the thing about the
British that made them very similar to
the Romans is they were relentless. They
were willing to suffer heavy casualties,
major setbacks, major fail failures, and
still persist until they eventually won,
okay? That's the mentality of the
British. That's very Roman.
All right.
So, um this is 1588, the Battle of the
Spanish Armada, okay? And this is
something that's heavily celeb-
celebrated in England because in for the
English, it marks the day when the
British Navy reigned supreme over the
seas. Okay, this is a day that the
Spanish Armada was conquered and
destroyed by the English. Um something
that's really important for us to
remember is that um
in a year later in 1589, the Spanish
will defeat the English, and the English
will suffer tens of thousands of
casualties. Okay? So, what's important
for us to remember is that these wars go
back and forth. There's no one time
when, okay, now the British are
dominant.
Okay? What matters is persistence, what
matters is resilience. And in this in in
that respect, the English are far
superior to the European
um adversaries.
Okay. Um
so Queen Elizabeth dies, and King James
of Scotland inherits the English throne,
okay? So, now Scotland and England are
united. What's significant about King
James is he produces them called the
King James Holy Bible. This is something
that the Protestants have been
um demanding for a long, long time.
Remember, the difference between the
Protestants and Catholics is the
Catholics are not allowed to read the
Bible, the priests tell
the uh parishioners what to believe,
what the orthodoxy is.
The Protestant believe that everyone
must read the Bible.
So, the King James Bible, it's the first
time that the Bible
has been mass-produced for everyone,
okay? So, this spreads Protestant very
quickly
throughout
the
um
uh
uh British Isles. Also, what's really
sig-
Middle English
to Modern English, the language we speak
today.
Um, 1620 is significant because it's the
year when the pilgrims on the Mayflower,
they moved to America to found a new
colony, a new civilization, a new empire
uh, that will take over the world, okay?
Why are the pilgrims moving to America?
Well, the Protestants are divided into
two major factions at this time. You
have the Puritans. Who are the Puritans?
The Puritans believe
that the Church of England it's too
Catholic.
And so therefore, we must purge the
Church of England of Catholic
tendencies, like rituals, like uh,
priest, okay?
The pilgrims are what we call
separatists, okay? So there's another
good point. The pilgrims are separatists
who believe the Church of England it's
too corrupt, it's too evil, it's too
much like the Vatican. Therefore, we
should abolish it or we should just
separate
uh, from it.
And so of course they were persecuted by
the king
and as a compromise, the pilgrims were
allowed to go to America to build a new
civilization based on their beliefs. And
this civilization of course will be
called America.
All right, so that's something that you
must remember that America was founded
by pilgrims who want to build a kingdom
uh, of heaven on Earth.
And we'll discuss this next week when we
discuss the American Revolution.
Back in
uh, England
there is a civil war now raging,
okay? And it starts again when the king
tries to impose too much authority over
the nobles, but there are there's also a
religious dimension to it
because the Puritans want to impose a
religious state on everyone, okay? So,
the fanatics at the other stage are the
Puritans. And what will happen is the
Puritans will emerge triumphant under
the leadership of Oliver Cromwell, and
he will establish something called the
Commonwealth of England. And this is a
disaster. It doesn't really work out
well because it goes against British
tradition. Remember, the idea of the
Puritans is they want to establish a
religious
centralized theocracy on England, but
England has always been
uh pretty independent and autonomous.
So,
what will happen is after Cromwell dies,
the Commonwealth goes away, and the
nobles reinstate a new king, okay? Uh
who is Charles II.
After he dies, James II will take the
throne. The problem with James II is
he's a Catholic.
Okay? He's a Catholic. And so, there are
a lot of English who are who are who are
afraid that he will he that he will move
too close to France, Spain, and the
Vatican. And these are
um
British enemies, okay? So, what will
happen is this. The nobles will invite a
Dutch king, William of Orange,
who who is of British um blood to come
to England in the year 1688. And like
William of William of Orange will bring
about 10,000 soldiers to Britain. This
is an invasion. This is the very last
invasion that succeeds in Britain. King
James has a larger army, but what
happened is King James is not very
decisive. He's not very effective. So, a
lot of his army will desert him. So,
basically his army sort of dis-
dissipates, and he's allowed to go to
France. And William of Orange
bloodlessly Not not not bloodlessly, but
he's but he's very quickly able to
assume the throne.
And this is significant because
and th- this is called the Glorious
Revolution. This is significant because
it establishes for the first time
officially the sovereignty of Parliament
over the king. Okay, does that Okay,
this is really important, okay? Now it's
official. Parliament is the ultimate
authority, ultimate sovereignty in
Britain. And the king is a figurehead.
All right. And this is significant
um because it will now allow
Britain to energize the middle class. If
you're middle class, you now have an
incentive to work hard because now
there's patents, there's trademarks.
There's incentive for you to get rich.
And this will lead to, of course, the
Industrial Revolution. All right. So,
the Glorious Revolution is one of the
main contributing factors to uh the
Industrial Revolution in Britain.
This is also significant because in
1694,
the Bank of England is established. All
right. Now,
I I can't emphasize enough
what a huge deal this is. All right. So,
let me slowly explain why this is a big
deal. And I want I want to make sure you
understand because now we're going to
into into finance and economics. And I
really haven't taught finance and
economics before. I I want to make sure
that you understand the idea here, okay?
So, before you're king,
and you want to fight a war, what you do
is you borrow money from the rich. And
these are usually cartels. All right.
So, um Charles II
borrowed a lot of money to fight wars
from the goldsmiths
of um London, including a group of Jews,
okay?
And then he refused to pay it back.
Now, you have a problem because now you
have
um a credit crisis. You have a trust
crisis, right? If the king refuses to
pay back the rich
for their
uh loan, why would the king ever be able
to raise funds ever again, okay? So,
Parliament solves this problem because
now because now if Parliament is the
central authority, the central
sovereignty in the land, then you are
not lending money to the king, you are
lending money to the nation.
Right? If a king dies or a king is
deposed, you're screwed. You're not
getting your money back.
But, if you lend money to the nation,
the people through the Parliament, then
you are always guaranteed to get your
money back
unless England gets conquered, okay?
But, we know because of the navy
England cannot be conquered. And so, not
only are the rich willing to lend money
to the nation now to finance wars, but
also foreigners, especially the Dutch.
Right? Because the Dutch were were very
wealthy, and they needed a safe place to
put their money. So, where where's the
safest place in the place in the world
to put your money now? England.
Right? Because if you are in the
Netherlands, you could be conquered by
the French or the Germans, which
happened which happens a lot.
But, if your money your gold, and this
is gold, right? Goes to London,
no one's going to touch that be able to
touch that, okay?
So, now
the Bank of England allows
Britain to borrow money from its people,
from foreigners, and from the future by
printing money, right? By issuing war
bonds. And therefore, Britain has
infinite financing.
And this is a major reason. This is the
main reason why Britain was able to
defeat Napoleon.
Right? It took seven wars, seven
coalitions to defeat Napoleon. Each of
these coalitions was financed by
Britain.
Okay?
And once Napoleon was defeated, Britain
became the hegemon of the world. It
became the British Empire. No one could
now challenge the might of Britain.
Okay.
So, do you understand the impact of
central banking? Okay? Central banking
allows you to mortgage your nation's
future in the pursuit of total war. It
allows you to weaponize the trust and
confidence of your people.
Okay? Does that make sense? But, there's
a problem. Okay? This is really
important. There's a problem with this
innovation. The problem is this.
Once you commit to a war, once you raise
debt and commit to a war,
you're forced to fight the war until the
very bitter end. Right? Because if you
lose the war, your nation goes bankrupt.
Does that make sense, guys? Okay? That's
why
Britain refused to ever compromise with
Napoleon.
And Napoleon said said to
Britain, "Hey guys, I control
all of Europe. Let's talk peace. Let's
just trade peacefully." And Britain
says, "No, we can't do that because we
lent a lot of money to the Austrians,
the Prussians, and the Germans, and the
Russians in order to defeat you. If we
sign a deal of peace, all this money is
now gone. And we, the Bank of England,
we, the British nation, is completely
wiped out. We are completely wiped out."
Okay? Do you understand? This is really
important for the future history of
Europe. If Britain fights a war, it does
so through financing. It does so through
debt. But, because it does so through
debt, it has to fight the war until it
wins.
It can never ever compromise. It can
never ever surrender.
All right?
And this is important because
this explains what happened in World War
I, World War II. And this also explains
and I'll I'll I'll discuss this
towards the end of the semester. It also
explains American foreign policy.
Okay?
Okay. Was that clear to you guys?
Any questions about what we've learned
so far?
Okay.
Now, I want to talk about political
philosophy
of the British, okay?
Because again, we discuss this
throughout um this course. You can have
new ideas, but now you have to justify
these new ideas. You have to explain uh
the innovation through philosophy to the
people, okay? So, um Britain at this
time is is really famous for its
political philosophers. At this time,
Thomas Hobbes
um is one of the most dominant political
philosophers. He lived through the
English Civil War. He saw all the chaos,
all the destruction. And he wrote a book
called Leviathan. Leviathan is to
justify why Britain returned to monarchy
instead of maintaining a commonwealth,
okay? And this is the most famous
passage from his book Leviathan, which
you'll probably read in university,
okay? There is no place for industry
because the fruit thereof is uncertain
and consequently no culture of the
earth, no navigation, nor use of
commodities that may be imported by sea,
no commodious building, no arts, no
letters, no society, and which is worst
of all, continual fear and danger of
violent death. The life of man solitary,
poor, nasty, brutish, and short, okay?
So,
um
he's trying to explain why there's
government.
And so, he gives the idea that we are
born in a state of nature. And we're
free to do what whatever we want. We can
kill, we can love, we can steal. We can
do what what we want. So, why would we
give up this freedom in order to enter a
state of nature? It is so in in order to
have government. And the answer is
because state of nature sucks, okay?
Because you can be killed because
because things will be stolen from you,
because there will be no innovation. So,
no matter how bad government is, it's
absolutely necessary.
Okay?
Now, this is John Locke.
Okay? And John Locke is writing during
the time of the Glorious Revolution. He
is a supporter of Parliament. He's a
supporter
of uh the Glorious Revolution. Okay? And
he and he writes something called uh so,
1688 is Glorious Revolution. In 1689, he
will publish
um the Second Treatise on Government.
And this is his most famous work. Okay?
Again, when you go to university, you
will have to study the Second Treatise.
But, in it, he basically explains that,
"Okay, Hobbes is right. We are born in a
state of nature and we do need
government, but let's remember this.
When we're born in a state of nature, we
are born with certain inalienable
rights. And these three rights are the
right to life,
liberty, and the pursuit of property.
Now, if proper function of government is
to maintain our rights. If the
government does not do that, then we
have the flexibility, we have the
freedom to rebel against the government,
okay? So, Hobbes is saying, "Government
is necessary. You can never ever
challenge it because if you do, things
will get much worse." Locke is saying,
"Government is only legitimate if it
guarantees us our inalienable rights."
Okay? So, Locke is considered the
founder of liberalism. And his ideas
will become the basis for the US
Constitution, which will which will
study next Thursday, okay? So, I I want
you to remember this. All right.
Now, what I'm doing now, and this is
really important, okay? Is compare and
contrast the British Enlightenment with
the European Enlightenment. Remember,
before we did the European
Enlightenment, we studied Rousseau, we
studied Kant,
uh Voltaire.
Okay? And I told you the British
Enlightenment is very different from the
European Enlightenment in three major
ways. Okay, so now what I will do is
explain what the differences are. Okay?
All right, so let's compare Rousseau and
Locke. Locke
um
uh published his theories um at the end
of the 17th century. Rousseau comes
about 50 years later, okay? And Rousseau
will give us the French Revolution.
So there are three major differences I
want you to remember between British
uh political philosophy and European
political philosophy.
Okay, the first is this. Locke believes
that we are born tabula rasa,
the blank slate, okay? Which means that
we are influenced by the environment.
If our parents are nice to us, we'll be
good people. If our parents are mean to
us, we'll become bad people. Tabula
rasa, okay? We are controlled, nurtured
by the environment.
Rousseau, the Europeans believe, "No.
We are born inherently good." Not only
that, we were born with a capacity to
reason if we are given the freedom to
reason. Remember when we discussed
Rousseau, he said, "Do not educate your
child before the age of 12."
Because if you do, you will just screw
up the child, okay? And the idea is
there's a natural capacity in us that
will grow over time that allows us to
reason naturally. So Rousseau believed
this, but also Kant believed this as
well.
Okay, so that's a huge difference.
Right? Second major difference is this.
Locke believes the purpose of society is
liberty. Liberty just means you are free
to do whatever you want. You want to eat
ice cream?
Go ahead and do it. Yes, ice cream will
make you fat. Ice cream will um
uh maybe increase your class
cholesterol, but you should have the
freedom, the liberty to to make that
choice, okay? That's the purpose of
society, to give you the liberty to make
bad choices.
For Rousseau, the purpose of society is
reason. Society, if it's good, should
enable you to reason properly.
Okay? So,
uh the Europeans believe that society
should be much more interventionist. It
should help you become more reasonable
because reason is what allows for
freedom. Okay?
All right. And the last major
difference, and this is key, okay, guys?
I I need you guys to remember these
three differences. The last major
difference is this.
How do you base laws? On what basis do
you have laws, okay? And so, for Locke,
the answer is very simple. Tradition,
guys. It's just what we've been doing
all this time, right? British common
law.
If the Romans did it
and we're still doing it, it's probably
for a reason. It's probably because it
works.
Okay? But, for Rousseau and the
Europeans, it's general will.
Remember Okay, so just remind you,
general will is what is in the best
interest of people. Okay? This is really
important. It's not what people want.
It's not what the majority says. It's
what is in the best interest of people.
So, Rousseau talked about this a lot
where Okay.
If you let the people If you let people
vote, there's a danger
that they'll be influenced by a minority
who manipulates them, okay?
The idea of the general will is Think
about this using your reason. Think
about what is in the best interest of
everyone.
All right. So, if everyone's like, you
know, I want free ice cream, okay? This
entire school says,
"I want free ice cream." Then, we should
give you free ice cream according to
Locke, right? But, according to
Rousseau, no, we cannot give you ice
cream because if you sit down
independently and think about what is in
your best interest, you would know that
ice cream is bad for you. Therefore, we
should not give you ice cream, okay? The
general will is what is in the best
interest of everyone involved.
Not necessarily what you vote for, not
necessarily what you believe, but what
is in your best interest, okay?
If you have reason, if you have the
capacity to reason.
All right? Now,
let's just summarize what the difference
is. The Europeans always asking, "What
is good? What is right?"
The British, and then later on the
Americans, only ask, "What works?" Okay?
What works?
What is the least worst world we can
live in, okay?
So, the British are practical. You can
you can also say the British are
utilitarian.
Where the Europeans are romantic and
they are idealistic.
All right?
Also, and this is really important
because Rousseau's line of thinking will
give us the philosophies of communism
and Nazism.
Okay? Does that make sense?
And of course, Locke's ideas will give
us the US Constitution, right? So, this
is part of the Anglo-American
political tradition. This will not
become the European tradition, which
will give us Marxism and communism.
All right. All right, let's continue.
So, one one of the most important
political philosophers in Britain is
Jeremy Bentham. And he's the founder of
something called utilitarianism.
Okay? So,
um
Bentham agrees with Locke in that we
need a more liberal society, we need a
more progressive society.
But for him, it's really a question of
like,
"How do you mathematically and logically
come to the point where you have a
tolerant, liberal, progressive society?"
And so, he develops the idea of
utilitarianism. Okay? The idea of you
utilitarianism is
there are two principles that govern the
universe, okay? That motivate us.
There's the pleasure principle and
there's the pain principle.
Okay? And so, what he says is, if if
something makes us happy, it's
inherently good. If something is makes
us
feel pain, it's inherently bad.
Okay? So we should we should structure
society that mathematically calculates
um the amount of pain and pleasure we
produce, and then we should maximize
the pleasure and reduce the pain. Okay?
And if if you do that, then you get to
the same point of Locke where people
should be guaranteed liberty. People
should be allowed to do whatever they
want as long as it doesn't really harm
other people. Okay? You want to eat ice
cream? Go eat ice cream.
You're not harming anyone.
All right?
Um
obviously there are lots of issues with
this theory of utilitarianism. So along
comes his disciple, John Stuart Mill.
And John Stuart Mill is considered
uh the most significant political
philosopher of the past 200 years.
Okay? He is the founder of what we call
classical liberalism. The very basis of
classical liberalism is people should be
free to do whatever they want as long as
it doesn't hurt anyone.
Also, people should be allowed to say
whatever they want because free debate,
free open debate is what allows for
society to progress. Okay? So what John
Stuart Mill does is he takes the
principles of utilitarianism and refines
it
um
in order to explain
why classical liberalism is the best
philosophy out there. Okay? And
classical liberalism will include
uh women's rights. Okay? It will include
prison reform. It will include uh a more
egalitarian society.
Okay?
All right. So
um
another thing that Locke sorry, John
Stuart Mill that does that's very
important is he explains pleasure is not
what you think it is. Okay? Pleasure
isn't like, okay,
whatever makes me happy because there
are different types of pleasure. There's
short-term pleasure and there's
long-term pleasure, right?
Short-term pleasure is eating ice cream
every day. Long-term pleasure is having
a healthy body and you can which which
allows you to climb mountains, which
allows you to
uh enjoy life more, okay? Short-term
pleasure is just watching TikTok videos.
Long-term pleasure is being able to read
Shakespeare, being able to read Dante,
and being able to enjoy life more, okay?
So, that is a major refinement of
Bentham.
Just because you enjoy something today
doesn't mean it's good for you. So, so
we have the capacity to understand
there's short-term pleasure and there's
long-term pleasure, okay? Long-term
pleasure is what he refers to as
happiness.
The purpose of life is to be happy. It's
not necessarily to seek pleasure. It's
It's but it's
the the purpose is to
um
to seek happiness, okay?
All right.
So, this is a very rough introduction.
Um you will learn all this stuff when
you get to university, okay?
All right. So,
the these are the reasons why the
British Empire came to conquer the
world, okay?
All right? It's history. It's geography.
It's demographics. Forces it to engage
in a continuous series of innovation.
This innovation will allow it to
eventually dominate the entire world.
And even though the British Empire is
gone, we still have the common the
British Commonwealth. Okay? So, these
are nations that speak English, that um
believe British culture it's the best in
the world, and who believe that
um
working together in a community will be
beneficial for all, okay? The British
Commonwealth.
Okay? And that's the legacy we still
have of the British Empire.
Okay. So, now that I've done
a brief introduction, what I want to do
now is summarize the main points so that
you
uh so that you have a pretty clear
framework to work with as we progress
into the American Empire. Okay?
All right.
So, what what we're going to do now is
just summarize what we've learned into a
story
of the British Empire.
All right? So, what what what's this
clear to you guys?
All right. So, let's now just summarize
what we've learned.
Sorry.
All right.
So,
there are many many reasons why the
British Empire came to dominate the
world, okay? But, the three things I
want to highlight today is
the Royal Navy.
Okay?
So, the thing to remember about the
Royal Navy is its main purpose is
actually not to engage in war and
conquest. Its main purpose is actually
to to maintain
global trade.
Why? Because, remember, Britain is the
first nation to industrialize.
Therefore, it's producing a lot of
finished goods. If you have finished
goods, you need markets. So, the Brit-
the the British Navy, its main purpose
is to open up new markets
and then to maintain safe trade routes
uh against pirates.
Okay? To facilitate global trade. So,
and this, of course, made Britain
extremely wealthy.
Second major reason is the Bank of
England.
All right? I cannot stress enough how
important this innovation was.
Also, what's really important for us to
remember is the Bank of England was
private.
Okay? Private. So, it had the powers
of a central bank,
the power to
print money,
issue currency, the power to issue debt,
sell bonds, but it was private, meaning
it was controlled by rich stockholders.
Okay? And the reason why they did this
is
um
it was just the easiest way in order to
raise money quickly. Okay? Um that makes
sense, right? Because if you're if
you're a public person, you may not want
to give your money to to the government.
But you're a rich person, where are you
going to put your money?
You're going to put your money
uh into a a central bank that's
that's supported by the government,
okay?
All right.
Uh and the third major reason is
English.
All right? So, the
development of English, which is again
the is the world's easiest language to
learn.
So, most languages
in order to speak it well, you have to
you have to you have to you actually
have to grow up
in a place, right? So, you don't you
want to speak Chinese very well, then
the best solution is to be born in
China.
But English is different. English is you
can learn at any age and still have a
pretty good command of the language.
Okay? That's a huge innovation
uh in human history. All right. So, now
let's let's try to figure out why was
England able to achieve these three
major innovations. Okay?
And not other places. Okay? The first
principle is the idea of open
cooperative
competition.
Which I'll explain, okay? Secondly is
the idea of creative destruction.
Meaning the elite is being constantly
replaced by a new elite that brings in
new ideas. And the third
is
expansion.
Okay? So, colonial expansion, where the
British are the English are forced to
migrate overseas and settle Canada, the
United States,
uh Australia, New Zealand.
Um and other places as well, okay? But
primarily these places. So, these are
the three major factors that drive uh
innovation. And because of all this
constant process of of innovation, you
have
Britain develop a navy, a bank, and a
new language that is fairly easy to
learn. All right.
Really quickly, I'm going to discuss the
idea of open corporate competition. All
right, so historically
civilizations develop
like on a major river.
So, if you look at China, China develop
on the Yangtze.
Egypt develop on the Nile. Mesopotamia
develop on the Tigris and Euphrates.
India develop on the Indus Valley, okay?
And the Ganges.
Why? Because if you have a major river,
you can build a settlement and then for
irrigation,
you can expand your population, okay?
And once your population expands, it
will allow you to colonize
other areas. And then your population
keeps on growing before it becomes
the dominant civilization in an era in
in an area, okay? Does that make sense?
Britain is different.
And Europe is different. Why? Because
there are no major rivers. And
therefore, the population
is constant. You never have a need to go
conquer new territory. You just want to
protect your your own territory.
Okay?
But because the population is so so
uh diffuse and
limited, it allows for foreign conquest.
Okay? Which allows for creative
destruction.
And that's the main factor driving
innovation in Britain.
Right?
So, that's the history of the British
Empire.
Any questions?
Anything you guys are not clear about?
Feel free to ask any question, okay? But
like please make sure you guys
understand the logic of this because
we're going to build on this as we go
further and further
uh
in into the present.
Okay? And remember, this is being
influenced by the Dutch
who will now and then this these ideas
will then go go on to influence America,
okay? So, America basically just takes
all the ideas of the British Empire for
itself.
All right? So, it's really important you
understand
what's driving the British Empire.
Just just a small question. Sure. Well,
you mentioned there are two
factions of Protestants, the Pilgrims
and
the
The
The Puritans.
So, they're both
Protestants?
Okay. Um all right, guys. All right.
So, let's go into
So, so question is, what's the
difference between the Puritans and the
Pilgrims, okay?
Um let's go into
the problem religion
in
England at this time, okay? So, when you
have
a diversity
Okay? When you have diversity in
England, and then so even though England
is a small place, as I keep on saying, a
lot of control is localized, okay? So,
if you cross from one village to the
next, the culture can be very different.
All right? So, this is a feudal system.
So, you have a lot of diversity. So,
this diversity is going impact your
religious outlook.
Okay? So
um what's going to happen is this.
So Eng- England's Catholic.
And then the Henry VIII is going to turn
this into the Church of
England.
But then what's going to happen is you
will have new ideas, basically
Calvinism,
come in from Europe. Okay? Why is
Calvinism important? It's because
England is the first to industrialize.
It's the first to have a middle class.
It's the first to have merchants.
Merchants prefer Calvinism
to Catholicism. Right? In Catholic in
the Catholic religion, you have to give
all your money to the church,
but in a Calvinist religion, you have to
keep your money for yourself. Right? So
Calvinism is a much more popular
religion in Britain than the Catholic
religion in England as England begins to
industrialize. And so the middle class
is rising
in power.
Okay?
And
the problem is the response to the
Church of England. Okay? The Church of
England, it's not Catholic, but it's
it's using a lot of Catholic principles.
And the Calvinists, the thing with the
Calvinists is they're fanatics, okay?
They they believe everyone should be a
Calvinist. Everyone should believe in
hard work. Everyone should be like us.
Okay? And the Pope is evil. So the Cal-
Calvinists are not very tolerant. So
there are two major responses to the
Church of England, okay? There's the
idea of reform
and then there's the idea of
dissolution.
All right? So the idea of reform is,
"Look,
the Church of England, it's fine, but
there are certain things within the
Church of England which is much like the
Catholic Church. So if we get if we get
rid of these things, we'll be good,
okay?
So, but within the reform movement, you
have different factions as well, okay?
So there's some who want to replace the
governance structure of the Church of
England because the Church of England is
controlled by the king.
And they believe, "No, we should all be
obedient to God, not the king." So they
they want to destroy the hierarchy, the
governance. There are some who want
everyone to read the Bible. There are
some who want to change the nature of
the priesthood, okay? So there are
different
theories of change, okay? And this group
of people we call the Puritans.
Okay, the Puritans.
But then you have a minority who are
extremely violent and fanatical and they
believe, "No, let's just get rid of the
Church of England, period, because there
should be no earthly authority before
God." Okay, and these people we call
Separatists.
Okay? And they will become the Pilgrims
because obviously the king will
persecute these people. They will feel
The king sees them as a threat and they
will be persecuted, they'll be outlawed.
A lot of them will be executed. So a lot
of them will flee to America in order to
practice their religion,
okay, in order to found a a new
religion.
All right, so the Pilgrims are the ones
who flee. The Puritans are the ones who
will stay and eventually engage in a
civil war and over for the king.
But remember this, okay? While this is
happening,
while this is happening, and this is
really important, there's also a
counter-reaction,
okay? So there are these Catholics
who want to return
England into the Catholic fold. And
there are
So Scotland is is very Catholic. Okay?
Um you also have
um other people called the Armenians
who
want to maintain the Church of England
as it is, okay? So, you have all these
massive factions emerging and they're
all in conflict over religion. And
religion is a proxy for
economic class as well.
Okay, so it's obviously the middle class
who support reform.
There are a lot of nobles who
support
the Catholic religion and the king is
primarily
a sympathizer of the Catholic religion,
all right? So,
during the Glorious Revolution, they
will make a stipulation
that no king can ever be a Catholic.
Okay?
And that's a way to limit the power of
the king because you're a Catholic king,
you can draw on the French, the Vatican,
the Spanish as allies in your
suppression of the nobles and then of
the middle class or Parliament, okay?
So, there's a there's a fear that the
king will ally with
the Catholic in order in order to
destroy the the authority of Parliament.
And so, after the Glorious Revolution,
a major reform is the king cannot be
Catholic.
And in fact, if you're the heir
to the throne, but if the Parliament
suspects you have Catholic sympathies,
they will replace you with someone else.
Parliament has that power and they and
they did that actually
during its history, okay?
So, there's a deep fear of the Catholic
religion within
the
within
the among English people, okay?
But as you can see, this is a very
complicated process that will take about
200 years to fully play out.
Okay? Does that Does that make sense?
What's the really important for us to
remember is this conflict is being
through the Pilgrims is is now migrating
to America.
And these people will make America into
the most religious
fanatical, intolerant place on Earth. In
certain places in America, okay? And
it's a tradition that still continues
today.
There are some certain parts of America
that are extremely tolerant, like New
York City and Los Angeles. But hey, go
to, I don't know,
Alabama, Mississippi,
Arkansas. They're not very tolerant
people, okay? And you can you can make
the argument that they are the most
fanatical people in the whole world,
much more so than the Jews, much more so
than
uh
the Muslims.
Okay?
So,
does that answer your question? Great.
Any more questions?
So, does the 50 British king actually
have any power because it seems like
a figurehead?
You know, that's a great question, okay?
So, how much power does a king have?
Okay. So,
um
the thing about the British is
because it's a system based on
tradition, there's a lot of flexibility
built into the system. So, depending on
the personality of the king,
the king can have a lot of power, okay?
So, for example, Henry the VIII
was a very powerful king. He can be
considered one of the most powerful
kings in the world. Why? First of all,
because he was a huge guy. He was
extremely charismatic. He was a huge guy
that was very good at winning friends
with the nobles, okay? So, he was very
good at building alliances.
Also, he was in power for a long, long
time, over 50 years.
Okay? So, he was able to slowly insert
his um
protégés, his minions into positions of
authority.
Okay? And also, uh he was also very
popular because he took England away
from the Catholic Church, okay? So, the
power of the king it's not written down,
and it has to do and a lot of his power
has to do with his personality,
um his longevity,
his alliances, his charisma. Okay, so
there are a lot of different factors in
place. And that's why the British think
their constitution is the most perfect
in the world because it's not written
down, so they're not actually
constrained by words.
It's but there's traditions that allow
the constitution to be living.
Okay? To be flexible and to be pertinent
to the present.
Okay? And and and and so the English are
extremely proud of their constitution.
Does that make sense?
Okay? If America learned this set of
mindset from the British, why are they
doing better in the modern society?
Okay. So, um,
that's a great question. So,
if these pilgrims went over to America,
how was America able to become this
multicultural empire, right? Because
that goes against a lot of
puritanical teachings.
And the answer, which we'll discuss next
week, is America
is
a coalition
of conflicts, okay? It is It is a
melting pot of differences.
Okay? So, what what I will teach you
next Thursday, when we do the American
Revolution, is there are two dominant
strands in the founding of America.
There's the pilgrim strand, which is
puritanical, which is like, let's create
a theocracy, but there's also a
enlightenment strand.
Where they believe that they're founding
a new empire
based on reason. And so, the religion we
use for them is
uh, deism, okay? These are deists. And
most of the founding fathers, Thomas
Jefferson, Alexander Hamilton, George
Washington, were deists. They wanted to
found a
tolerant
multicultural
empire. Okay? So, these are two dominant
strands
in America. And quite honestly, what's
really important is if you understand
what's happening in America today,
Donald Trump, right? You need to
understand that it's these two strands
that have always been present in America
that are coming to conflict with each
other. Okay? Because you have on the
left these multiculturalists,
um like Barack Obama, who believe that
America is great because America
welcomes immigrants. And you have people
like J.D. Vance, and and there are lots
of others as well on on the conservative
side who say, "No, America is great
because we are Christian."
Okay? Because we have this tradition
of Christianity. That's what makes us
great. And right now we're losing our
Christianity due to multiculturalism,
and therefore we must close our borders.
Therefore, we we must reassert the
Christian faith in our nation.
Okay? So so so we will discuss this next
Thursday when when we do America, but
this will but but but as we as this
course progresses, I will show you
how complicated America is. And show you
um that because of this conflict,
America's probably is probably headed
towards a civil war.
Okay? If if that makes sense to you.
All right. Great. Any more questions,
guys?
Okay. So um next class we will do
William Shakespeare.
And then after William Shakespeare,
we'll do the American Revolution.
Okay?